things got heated at the White House on
Friday when President Trump hosted a
meeting on underage vaping the president
had promised months ago it's a band most
flavored cigarettes in the wake of a
number of vaping related illnesses and
deaths but he has since reconsidered
Kenneth Craig has more on whether that
plan has gone up in smoke Kenneth's good
morning good morning to you those
discussions at the White House included
representatives of the vaping industry
health experts and anti tobacco
activists the president seems to support
raising the minimum age to purchase
e-cigarettes from 18 to 21 but right now
it's unclear just where the president
might come down on a ban of any vaping
products we want to take care of our
kids Friday's event contrasted sharply
with the president's announcement in
September which raised the prospect of a
widespread ban on flavored cigarettes
this time he listened and asked
questions what about the concept of
every state decides but declined to say
what he might do Henry armours national
association of convenience stores
represents more than 150 thousand
businesses across the u.s. Utah senator
Mitt Romney who recently introduced a
bill that would ban flavored cigarettes
and tax the industry wasn't buying it
the Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention says more than a quarter of
all US high school students admit to
vaping
in the last month there is not just one
type of disease you can get from
e-cigarettes and this week the American
Medical Association called for a total
ban on all east cigarette products that
do not meet FDA approval as smoking
cessation tools the president seems
sympathetic to the industry
representatives argument that banning
flavored products could create a black
market but he has also faced political
pressure on this issue from vapors who
have vowed not to vote for him if he
supports the ban and you heard him hint
that maybe in a decision would be coming
soon yeah it's interesting too I was
saying while we were watching the piece
the difference between Flay
and the non-flavored east cigarettes if
you're trying to get off smoking are you
going for the flavor are you going for
the others if that's the argue that it
seems the concern right now at least
with this meeting is young children who
are addicted in part because of those
flavors Kenna thank you